a bullet when fired underwater moves
with it says deceleration silly moves
with deceleration proportional to its
velocity so the X double dot equals
negative kV for some positive constant K
its initial speeds half a kilometer per
second its speed after it's gone 50
meters is 250 meters per second find X
as a function of time okay what would
you like me to do okay so I've given you
this tremendous leader I told you hey
hey hey you better use this but of
course you know to use that because why
because it's in terms of velocity okay
so I'm going to say V DV on DX is
negative KB just like I did before I'm
going to yep
what would you like me to do okay yeah
interestingly what radon is pointing at
is this thing is just a constant so if I
wanted to I actually could go ahead and
I could integrate right now would that
be useful to me because I don't know I
don't know anything that's gonna get me
here look at all this information that
I've got right what it relates is not
really useful it's not to be as useful
okay
so I'm going to flip it upside down now
I'm going to integrate right actually go
what you know what I'm gonna take you
down the garden time because I can't no
trust me trust me remember all this work
we've been doing with inverse functions
and all that kind of thing in theory
either way we go about this should be
fine right isn't it there's not the
algebraic stopping me so let's give it a
go okay what am I gonna get on the
left-hand side want to integrate just
city ok on the right-hand side
I integrated with respect to X and
there's a constant that's a really bad
gracious given it okay now he's where my
brain was going and as I was thinking on
the fly I can still use this color I can
still find out what the cost it is how
do I do it so I have a condition here
now I wonder if in the last two enough
minutes maybe what is the notice what's
missing because I do have that condition
but I'd rather not use it just yet
anyway can I read the question again for
you right because I read it out for you
and then you told me to write this
algebra you did some interpretation when
you did that its initial speed is half a
kilometer per second and it's speed
after it has gone 50 meters is 250
meters per second you all told me to
write this down but no no no one told me
where you started who said X is 50 now
I'm not saying X isn't 50 but if X is 50
at this time then what does that mean
about this you all kind of assumed this
now that's okay it's okay to assume that
I now remember I told you you can put
the origin wherever you live right but
you all kind of just artfully dodge that
you saw all 50 it's gone 50 X must be 59
can start any way you like right now I'm
going to choose a value that's
convenient
I think X equal zero is a great place to
start why not okay there's nothing the
question told you not to
so that was missing but no one really
noticed it well in this case I haven't
been given any point of reference or
anything all right so I can make X equal
zero where vampire-like and I choose
what's convenient to me I could have
made this x equals zero and that would
have made this x equals negative 15
would have been fun
I'm gonna use my initial condition which
time is not relevant to it move but I'm
just gonna pair up these two guys okay
so I'm gonna say when X
zero V is equal to five okay so the
reason why I wanted to use this one I
mean you could use this you could but
this is just going to give me easier
numbers because zero will make things
cancel out right this is going to be
zero
so can someone tell me what C is gonna
be able to so I've got V equals negative
K X plus 500 I've got a second constant
to solve for and I'm gonna use the
second condition to use two software
right so I'm gonna say when where other
where x equals 50 V equals 50
so now I'm gonna pop these numbers it
looks like - 50 K plus 500 that's a
really bad thing sorry equals 250 250
what time did you know okay so that
gives me negative 250 over here and then
divide through cool so what do they got
now I have a velocity function in terms
of displacement what was I trying to get
to
displacement in terms of time so I need
to push time back into this equation how
do I do that again I recognize what V is
V stands for velocity which is changing
displacement versus change in time so
this is DX DT all right the positive one
okay now what I need to integrate with
respect to X because that right-hand
side is in terms of X so therefore I
need to take the reciprocal so then I'm
all talking in the same language
yeah okay cool cool all right we're
almost there in fact we've done all the
heavy lifting
yeah there's just a little bit of um a
little bit of algebra mud walls maybe to
do you too much right next
I've already use this but I've only used
part of it so I'm gonna use it again I'm
going to say when T equals 0 x equals
zero right so let's go here what am I
going to get
how's that what you think look happy did
Jim numbers right so I've got my
constant sitting right there hundred and
now I'm ready to put it back in there
and I'm pretty much well you know I need
to change the subject but that's okay
that's not hard to do what have I got
there I'm gonna put the posit number at
the front is that okay I don't look a
little bit neater yeah
now in this case unlike before there is
a clear advantage geez my locals here
right because then I'll just have a
single long expression of you what would
you like me to do take out a fit that
leaves you with more takeaway log when
you subtract logs you divide so this is
100 on 100 takeaway X yep that's my
expression 15 gonna be a little bit
cheap I'm gonna multiply both sides by 5
in one go and then what do I do to both
sides here you usually go in the
opposite direction I'm going to I'm
gonna raise both sides I'm gonna use
both of these as the powers and I'm
gonna make it the base does that make
sense
so this is actually e to the log blah
blah blah blah which is just blah blah
blah blah I'm gonna have to take the
reciprocals again
I'll put it over here what what's this
okay I'm almost there I'm almost there
let's most went through by a hundred
then I'm gonna add X to both sides take
away that from both sides said okay that
should land me on this
what do you think yes happy now of
course secondary question could get
asked I'm not that [ __ ] right now is
briefly describe evolution that'll be a
natural thing to ask next you could draw
yourself because this is a displacement
in terms of time you could even just
draw yourself a nice easy graph on that
look at this does that look familiar by
the way isn't that a kind of modified
growth and decay situation sir this is a
very easy graph to draw and then you can
describe the motion you could tell me
where it starts you can tell me what's
leading behavior as time fritz in 30
years and on another note okay so this
is not too hard the hardest thing about
this is work out what you have to do
which one you have to be respected
because if you choose the wrong one
you're just gonna make lots and lots of
progress down something which is not
going to get you there and then just be
careful with your duties don't be afraid
to take the reciprocal in fact sometimes
you kind of have to awful times
sometimes and if you're patient with it
and know which conditions to use when
you find any questions
oh one last thing because people always
forget it
Constance I kind of haven't written it
because you can see all I'm integrating
lots of times so you don't have to write
all I need you're going with Spencer you
enjoy anything to you but probably the
most dangerous thing about skipping the
recce like I have just done these people
forget to put the in Constance and so
you're assuming the constantly zero
basically and I don't think I need that
constant to 0 is it not okay okay so
obviously if you're super constant is
zero that's going to kind of drastic
wind markup you're working okay